pierre bellemare comment vendriez vous
un vibromasseur qui se recharge sur
l'allume-cigare
[Rires]
je commencerai par dire
chers amis oui l'objet que je vais vous
d'ordre doit absolument être utilisée
sur un parking et en aucun cas pendant
la marche des véhicules en effet à
partir du moment où vous avez branché
sur un petit gars le vibromasseur que je
vais maintenant vous proposer
tout est possible le nirvana peut
arriver et donc il est impossible de
jouir jo nirvana si en même temps est en
train de doubler nos deux chaînes de 2,9
sur le tour bravo version
[Applaudissements]
reviendrions
pierre bellemare aurait lui aussi joué
dans un péplum il pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu